in the last five years we've created in
this country two million apprenticeships
here in the East of England about
177,000 people have started an
apprenticeship under this government and
businesses like this are investing in
apprenticeships and that is all to the
good I want us to raise the ambition to
raise the goal and to set for the next
parliament the goal of three million
apprentices and what I want to get to is
a situation where if you're young and
growing up in Britain as you're coming
out of school you have a choice a choice
about going to university and studying
or a choice about taking on an
apprenticeship and earning and learning
at the same time I want to see fewer and
fewer people and eventually know people
who leave school without either taking
one of those two paths because we're
going to succeed as a country we want to
have a trained and skilled workforce
with an opportunity for every young
person to make the most of their talents
to an apprenticeship or university or
college for everyone in our country